hey everybody its charlie warner
brothers just screened the joker movie
for critics so i had a chance to see it
early we're allowed to post our
non-spoilery reviews and reactions so
we'll try to explain as much as possible
about the movie why everyone's going
crazy about it why critics seem to love
it so much and why it will change DC
movies or certain kinds of DC movies
forever
is sort of a watershed moment the same
way that Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy was a watershed moment no joke
you have to go see this movie even if
you're not a huge fan of The Joker
character you're not a big comic book
fan it is a very important moment in
superhero cinema and I will explain
because technically it's not so much a
superhero film as it is a really deep
character study and meditation on a
single character
we'll do a giveaway for movie tickets
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite Joker
moment from the comics or from any of
the previous movies so far on this video
you've probably been reading a bunch of
interviews with todd phillips the past
couple of weeks talking about how this
is definitely not meant to be a
superhero film that way you would
traditionally think of a comic book DC
superhero film like justice lee Batman V
Superman Aquaman the Wonder Woman movies
even the Harley Quinn birds-of-prey
movie which just drops a little trailer
which I'll be doing a video for later
today you have all this stuff around the
Joker you've seen him in all these other
films but this film is meant to be so
different from the way they make those
other films if you're a big fan of
martin scorsese and you've seen any of
the Joker trailers you're probably
getting serious Travis Bickel taxi
driver vibes from Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker in the director was very clear
that he was inspired by a bunch of
different really classic films so I
should get a little more excited the
1928 classic film the man who laughs
which is also partially inspiration for
the comic book origin of the Joker
Scorsese's taxi driver of course the
king of comedy which you've also seen a
lot of references to in the trailers so
far in One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
Joaquin Phoenix said that he wanted his
performance to not be easily
identifiable or classifiable by any kind
of psychiatrist or mental health
professional he said that he didn't want
his version of the Joker which is named
Arthur Fleck within the world of this
movie which is also another departure
from the comics which I'll talk about in
a second
- but he said he wanted to create
something totally new free from any sort
of pre-existing continuity it's not
meant to be tied to Justice League the
DC EU films they're calling it DC black
label or at least todd phillips the
director is calling a DC black label he
told this amazing story about how long
it took him to convince DC in warner
brothers to let him make a movie like
this with a character this big one of
the earlier conversations he said that
he had with them was them telling him
you realize that we sell joker pajamas
at Target kids are running around in
Joker pajamas and you want to make this
crazy taxi driver r-rated hardcore
meditation on the character it took a
full year of todd phillips grinding them
down convincing them before they would
say yes to it so this film has been in
the works for way longer than you might
have thought this was all happening
while things were going really crazy in
and around the Justice League premiere
and we were finding out about all the
things happening behind the scenes those
bigger more commercial DC films the DC
Universe however you want to think about
it went through their own reinvention in
that period going off in a much brighter
direction than previously it seemed like
they were going so the way they're
talking about this new Joker film is
that it's the beginning of what you
would call DC black label in the same
vein as their comic book DC black label
if you're not a big comic book reader
what DC did is just to sort of build on
the idea of the DC brain because
everybody knows DC Comics when you see
DC comics on a comic book that's meant
to be their mainstream titles like
Batman Superman Justice League Wonder
Woman Green Lantern Corps any kid could
walk into a comic book shop or wherever
comic books are sold and read one of
those enjoy it have fun have a really
cool story but it's also a little bit
more mature they call it teen plus so
like an edgier version of something that
would be okay for a thirteen-year-old
but also okay for someone who's 1819 or
even older and has been reading the
character for the last 20 or 30 years
the new DC black label is meant to fill
the gap that the Vertigo brand used to
very adult stories not meant for kids
just really hardcore stuff like the boys
series on Amazon you may have seen
recently everyone was going crazy about
that originally started as a vertigo
title it's so crazy that there's no way
that DC Comics would ever put their name
on it but for a little while
DC was publishing that comic book
underneath their vertigo brand so that's
why you have this new movie DC black
label where you want to make this really
cool hardcore r-rated Joker film but you
can't really put DC's name on it so to
speak because DC and Warner Brothers
want your average family to see the DC
name on stuff and know that it's okay
for families it's sort of a Disney brand
type of issue so that's where DC black
label comes in so if the Joker movie is
as successful with audiences as it is
with critics and they decide to embrace
the idea of the DC Black Label movie
they put a slightly different title and
intro sequence on it so that anybody
that brushes by a poster or a trailer or
sees a clip knows exactly what the tone
is and who it's intended for like oh
this is a really cool film about this
character but I probably shouldn't take
my kids to this if you do happen to have
children and you just took them to see
Avengers Infinity Ward obviously this is
way more hardcore if you feel like you
could show them taxi driver and they
could understand it or they wouldn't be
traumatized by it too much then you
could probably take them to the Joker
movie because it very much is taxi
driver with the Joker if Martin Scorsese
was making a superhero comic book film
Joaquin Phoenix's performance is amazing
but I think part of the reason why the
movie works so well is because todd
phillips sort of freed himself from the
idea that he was trying to tie this in
with any kind of pre-existing continuity
it wasn't trying to reference any of the
other iterations of the Joker that came
before like we all talk about Heath
Ledger's Dark Knight Joker as being one
of the best performances of that
character Mark Hamill's Joker on Batman
the Animated Series one of the best
Joker's of all time this is meant to be
something completely different from that
Joaquin Phoenix didn't go back and watch
any of those other films he wanted
something to be completely unique so you
could look at him and not be confused
when you see some other version of the
Joker and one of the other Batman movies
so you may be disappointed if you were
looking for this to tie in with the
other larger DC Universe like you're not
gonna see Joaquin Phoenix show up in
Matt Reeves Batman film even though I'm
sure there's gonna be a ton of videos
trying to tie this film to that film it
is a very big departure on the origin
story that you know from the comics and
they're technically three versions of
the Joker because as part of the new
comic book DC black label Jeff
is doing a comic book called the three
Jokers
this is the comic book way to try to
explain how there are so many different
versions of the Joker's origins story
because up to this point in the comics
he had no definitive origin story that
was kind of the point of the character
he's been this wonderful engine of chaos
for so many years driving all these
Batman stories but various times you'll
have different writers come on and write
a slightly different version of the
origin story most people are probably
familiar with the Red Hood version of
the Joker origin story or say like the
Tim Burton origin story where he falls
into the vat of acid in ace chemicals I
feel like it's not a spoiler to say that
there's no version of that kind of comic
book origin story in this movie it's a
very taxi driver descent into madness
origin story it's meant to be 70s Gotham
like 70s New York before it got cleaned
up before the Disneyfication of Times
Square when you couldn't walk through
Times Square without walking by one of
the peeps shows this version of Gotham
is just meant to be the darkest timeline
version of New York City in the 70s the
film also does a lot of commentary on
the way mental illness is treated and
perceived in modern society through a
lot of his characters around the Joker
character or Arthur Fleck before he
becomes it embraces the Joker persona
like you see him talking to the
psychiatrist during the last big trailer
and he feels like she doesn't listen to
him you have no idea what's going on
with me all of my thoughts are dark
thoughts so we think a lot of you will
probably go into the film understanding
that even though he might see himself is
the protagonist of his own story this is
a movie where there are no real heroes
so to speak unless you count a very
young version of Bruce Wayne that will
someday maybe become Batman because
everything that happens in this film is
very different than what you've seen in
previous Batman origin stories so be
free to speculate about what might
happen if they do more sequels todd
phillips hasn't been talking too much
about doing direct sequels to this movie
but I'm sure they would come back to the
table he's mostly been talking about the
advent of DC black label films so what
he might do instead of doing a direct
Joker sequel if this one was really
successful it's just do the same thing
with another DC character either a
villain or a hero doesn't necessarily
have to be a villain part of the reason
why Todd Phillips was able to get this
film greenlit is because he only
fifty-five million dollars making it
most of the smaller what you would
consider DC movies like Shazam or ninety
million dollars by example and that's
because they have a lot of special
effects a much bigger cast this film
doesn't have any of that so this is a
drop in the bucket compared to what they
spend on the traditional big DC level
films like the Wonder Woman sequel
Wonder Woman 1984 probably spent over
150 million dollars making that movie so
with they do more DC Black Label films
it would be smaller lower budget films
like this so there are only certain
characters for which that would work so
you might be able to do a Lex Luthor
origin story before Superman arrives in
Metropolis you might be able to do a
Deathstroke movie like there's the Joe
Manganiello Deathstroke movie that they
were originally going to make which now
seems like it's never gonna happen but
maybe they could rewrite that film to be
like the Joker DC Black Label film deep
character study on who Deathstroke is
and why he does the things he does how
he became Deathstroke this is also the
same reason why they were so quick to
greenlight the birds of prey movie
because Harley Quinn is a character in
those other characters even though they
do have a lot of weapons and there's
more characters in the film does it
require really big crazy effects like a
Superman movie does or even a Wonder
Woman movie but everybody let me know in
the comments if they do more r-rated DC
black label films for villains or maybe
even for Heroes which characters do you
want them to do it was a brand new
birds-of-prey trailer that they secretly
dropped in front of the spider-man far
from home rerelease that was disguised
as a trailer for the it movie but then
suddenly changes to a birds-of-prey
trailer I'll do a video for that next
that should be up later tonight early
tomorrow morning everybody click here to
rewatch that last big Joker trailer and
click here for my video of all the
brand-new deleted scenes that they added
you